for about the last 35 years or even
longer I've been asking students to work
on neighborhoods in New York City to do
research and get out into the city but
what happens over the years is you
accumulate a filing cabinets full of
information and some are good and some
are not good but almost all are just a
dialogue but between you and the
students and with the development of the
internet and more sophisticated
technological tools it becomes possible
to obviously save these and share them
but I also one of them because we could
do more and keep them more and
presumably by putting them on the web
and making them available at least at
some point to a wider audience then they
really need to have a little more
quality to them this project gets them
to get into neighborhoods that otherwise
would never see their people to go to
Columbia University and well they know
where the Meatpacking District is then
anywhere Greenwich Village is they can
get there and then go to Times Square
but they've never been to Brooklyn and
the Bronx that might as well be on the
moon and yet those are part of the city
as well and so first of all I'm getting
them out second of all I think I'm
teaching them a little bit about how
history itself is done that it can be a
combination of both interviews and
documentary research and then thirdly I
think then here's certainly the hope
that we're creating something here at
Columbia that has legs that as we refine
it and develop it and spread it out both
horizontal on Hera's on tily and make it
give it more depth that we can create
something that's unique that's not done
in New York and maybe not be done is not
done anywhere and that we can then make
it available to maybe to the
neighborhood itself I mean I think you
know I want to get ahead of myself I'm
no expert on this but I think the
potential for the future is quite large
they know they're not just doing this
tim is a make-work project just to
satisfy some academic requirement I
don't think there's anything wrong with
work just for an academic requirement
but this goes beyond their this this is
quite explicitly something where we hope
that you will produce something that
will be interesting to somebody who
never been to Columbia never been to
this class couldn't care less about it
but does care about tottenville and
Staten Island or great kills in Staten
Island which otherwise would have been
completely ignored by people to Columbia
so I think I think it's potentially
beneficial in many ways with the help of
the Center for a new medium teaching and
learning it allows us the possibility
some of them can do it themselves some
of them need help but to broaden their
presentation by using video clips by
using photographs that are historic by
using interviews by making the
presentation itself not interactive but
more active period and this is something
that you can do obviously on the web
when you can't do it in just traditional
written history papers it's not just
line the other piece of paper it can be
visualized and so I think that's two
different ways to see it and we want
them to in a sense be measured on both
both sides of that be happy but I do
think that some percentage of those
students will be seriously energized by
this and really really want to take
other people there and really become
interested in a part of the city in the
world that they never thought existed
and my larger goal is to it's arrogant
to say this but to change the lives of a
few people to get them excited about
something in a way they weren't excited
before to change the trajectory of their
life or even if you don't change the
trajectory of their life and
live all their lives in Montana to
realize or think that there's some value
in piling everybody up in one ant hill
where everybody's different and and you
have to share a lot of space and a lot
of problems I think for the world in the
21st century New York is a pretty good
example of in some ways how to do it how
to do it without conflicts how to do
without everybody going to war with each
other I mean after all you put hundreds
of literally ethnic groups here in all
the shared space there is an experiment
going in the city and that actually
people love the city and so even if most
of them will never be there again I want
them to love the past and appreciate the
past and remember that we build on the
past we don't just create anything out
of whole cloth and that that's part of
it too either love history or respect
history and the other part is to feel
the same way about New York City even if
you decide you know I really do want a
garden I really do want to have a horse
I really do want my children to be a go
outside and owned as far as they can see
if that's what you want that's okay but
to still have a sympathetic place in
their heart for a different choice and
to believe that we shouldn't all go to
Walmart and shouldn't all live in a
suburban situation that there should be
difference in the United States and in
manhattan and New York City and the
outer borough sort of celebrate that
difference or make it possible and I
hope that they get some of that from the
Sun